tu marches juste quand même
tu as un sacré rythme de course c'est
d'un pas assuré que Raphaël moffali
traverse les rues d'Orléans chaque mois
il continue de tester ses réflexes avec
sa psychomotricienne
il y a beaucoup de rigueur beaucoup
d'attention à apporter sur tout un tas
d'éléments le fait de pouvoir marcher
sur une ligne droite c'est de pouvoir
percevoir par le toucher de la canne
plein d'éléments de particularité de
pouvoir score donner et en même temps on
est attentif quand est-ce qu'on arrive à
un carrefour qu'est-ce qu'on entend
qu'est-ce qu'on perçoit par tous les
autres sens
ces séances personnalisées sont
proposées grâce à la Maison de la
déficience visuelle et de l'autonomie
sur place l'association compte plus
d'une quinzaine d'employés cours de
braille aide administrative loisirs plus
de 250 aveugles et malvoyants viennent
s'y retrouver le sport est un remède le
sport est un pont entre nous et les
autres entre les autres et nous dans les
deux sens
l'essentiel du temps je suis je suis
assez seul oui pour ne rien cacher ça
permet aussi d'avoir des contacts
sociaux
avec d'autres membres de l'association
véritable plateforme de services cette
maison adaptée est unique dans la région
est rare dans le reste du pays ne prend
pas du tout en considération les besoins
des personnes qui sont pourtant
importants puisque l'objectif
aujourd'hui c'est quand même l'autonomie
et la prévention de la perte d'autonomie
dans un contexte de vieillissement de la
population où les plus de 60 ans
développent des pathologies notamment
sensorielles et auditives des lieux
essentiels dans une société
vieillissante d'ici 2050 les plus de 65
ans représenteront 28% de la population